Britain's main opposition Labour Party's
unveiled its manifesto for the December
12th general election leader Jeremy
Corbyn outlined what he would do if he
becomes Prime Minister he's promised
what many are calling a radical and
ambitious plan the Labour Party wants to
nationalize certain industries to give
people another sale breaks it and to
increase taxes on the richest this party
this movement this manifesto is
different labour is on your side and
there could be scarcely a clearer
demonstration of that than the furious
reaction of the richest and most
powerful if the bankers billionaires and
the establishment thought we represented
politics as usual then we could be
bought off that nothing was really going
to change
they wouldn't attack us so ferociously
live now to Birmingham in the UK where
that manifesto was launched out of zeros
Paul Brennan is there it's been
described as the most radical labor
manifesto in decades Paul what's in it
yes I mean it's been also described as
probably the purest distillation of
jeremy corbyn's view on politics overall
I mean he's basically thrown everything
that he possibly can at this it is the
pinnacle if you like of his political
career he's you know he really has
listed everything that he wants to to
change in the UK I have the manifesto
here
105 pages little red book and the
contents of it journalists are still
pouring through but I can give you some
of the headline differences the reforms
that he's proposing a living wage what
he calls a real living wage of the
equivalent of around $13 an hour a
million green jobs for climate change at
nationalizing broadband and some of the
what he called natural monopolies such
as the railways water energy the mail
and the railways sorry I said and water
also abolishing tuition fees for higher
education and university students now
obviously in a place like this that went
down particularly well with the the
audience
in the room listening other ones though
a one-off windfall tax on oil companies
and I understand there was some dilemma
within the shadow cabinet within jeremy
corbyn's cabinets about that fearing
that it might damage the north sea oil
industry but nevertheless it is in there
although not in very specific terms
how does he propose to pay for all of
this poor well he insists that it's
fully costed in addition to this
document
there was another document to kind of
great pamphlets the estimate of a cannot
economists is that it's going to cost
the equivalent of around ninety billion
dollars to pay for this plan but the
Labour Party says that they have gone
through it with a fine-tooth comb that
they have the funds that they have the
tax proposals to actually fund this
fully and they are saying that this is
not some kind of magic money tree but
they actually do have the proposals to
do it now what was interesting though is
in proportionate in proportion to the
radical nature of this document what
they're saying is that judge it by the
opposition that it generates it's quite
a radical strategy to sell it to the
public effectively they're saying all of
those critics and however loudly they
shout about this and try to say that
it's rubbish and that it won't work that
will be evidence of just how good it is
so it's an interesting an interesting
tactic that the Labour Party are putting
forward for this to win over voters
ahead of that vote on December 12th or
many thanks indeed Paul Brennan there
live in Birmingham Chris Stafford is a
researcher at the Center for British
politics at the University of Nottingham
he joins us now via Skype from
Nottingham good to have you with us
Chris Labour running well behind the
Conservatives at the moment in the
opinion polls will this manifesto change
their fortunes well it remains to be
seen really doesn't it I think there
certainly certainly pulling out all the
stops to turn it around
yeah well it's definitely paying to call
them strength so you know maybe you know
hopefully for him to say it might might
help yeah remains to be seen really is
there an appetite in Britain for for
such a
radical manifesto as Labor's I think
there definitely is
the Corbin octagon you have a very
strong core support base and there they
will definitely they definitely call
them the kinds of things he's he's
composing whether it whether it strikes
a chord with them or sort of general
population again remains to be seen but
I think I think a lot of the things he's
proposing will certainly be attractive
to people whether whether it's
attractive enough to convince them to
vote for him or the Labour Party leads
the course that's a very different issue
as Paul Brennan was saying a lot of the
policies will appeal directly to younger
voters who have a history in the UK of
not turning out to vote in elections
will this be enough do you think to get
them to the polling booths it's yeah
it's I think I think there's a good
chance it will certainly encourage many
many people to show up certainly you
know promising to abolish Jewish indeed
will only be quite popular students so
you know although young people are
notorious for not turning out to votes
certainly a lot of these policies are
very attractive to young people so
there's there's a good chance that it
could be convinced a lot of young people
to turn out though there does seem to be
a lot of dissatisfaction with with the
current politics among among younger
people so yeah potentially they could
increase turnout
okay Chris good to talk to you many
thanks to being this Chris Stanford
there in Nottingham